a massive data leak has revealed the
secret financial dealings of some of the
world's richest and most powerful people
the so-called pandora papers show how
world leaders business tycoons and
celebrities hide their wealth using tax
havens now the investigation was carried
out by the international consortium of
investigative journalists with partners
including dw's turkish service it
exposed hundreds of high-level
politicians and public officials around
the world who are linked to offshore
accounts
and i'm joined now from washington d.c
by will fitzgibbon he's a reporter with
the icij which obtained these records
and shared them with a group of news
organizations very warm welcome to the
show tell us first of all how did these
millions of documents from 14 different
offshore entities end up in the hands of
you and your colleagues
well many of your listeners will know
icij from our past investigations like
the panama papers investigation the
pandora papers really then is another
example of what we've been doing for
many years which is obtaining leaked
records especially about the offshore
system and collaborating then with
hundreds of journalists to make sure
that every country and every potential
politician
or even criminal in the documents that
we have are found exposed and reported
on now we heard in that report that the
king of jordan's name appears in the
pandora papers as does that of the czech
prime minister i mean more than 300
public figures in all what is it that
links these cases together
you're right the pandora papers really
is jaw-dropping
in the degree to which politicians past
and present are represented we did not
expect to find so many politicians when
we started searching through these
confidential files more than a year ago
and what links them really is
power
and wealth these are nearly always
powerful and wealthy people who for
whatever reason
actively choose themselves or through
their advisors to set up secretive
companies in order to make deals or own
property in ways that really average
people like you and i don't do if i'm
interested in buying a house i'm going
to register it in my name if i want to
sign a contract i'll do it in my name
and yet the pandora papers really
reveals how for many politicians with
money and power they choose to use
a secretive system now just to be clear
is what they are doing here illegal or
is it just that they have found a
loophole that benefits
the powerful to try and not pay their
fair share
it's an important question now in most
countries but not all owning a shell
company or using a shell company is not
in and of itself illegal and we have not
made that assertion in any of our
reporting as it relates to the king of
jordan or the prime minister of the
czech republic but there are issues much
more important or as important i should
say than illegality and that is when
leaders of countries who
represent us
let alone those like the king of jordan
and the prime minister of the czech
republic who have openly spoken about
the need for transparency and the ills
of corruption and illicit financial
flows when those people themselves
we find have not ever disclosed as in
some cases in the czech republic they
were required to do so on declaration
forms when they've not disclosed their
ownership or ties to shell companies
then really it puts into question the
whole
transparency model of democracy and rule
of law upon which so many of our
societies are based and with that in
mind what impact do you hope that these
revelations are going to make
it's
we're a few hours into the pandora
papers only and trust me there are many
many more stories to come
journalists generally don't think about
or plan what impact may or may not
happen
what we do know however is that there's
a huge interest among
members of the public among lawmakers
among the fbi among all kinds of
investigators around the world who for
decades have known that shell companies
have been central to cases of tax
evasion and wrongdoing and so there is
an appetite to reform the system really
the question is
are other people in power who we've now
revealed to benefit from the offshore
system are they really the right people
who will be in a position to fix the
ills that we've identified
certainly an important question thank
you so much will fitzgibbon reporter
with the icij in washington dc
thank you